et pour l'heure Lucas l'inquiétude à
Vigné après des cas avérés de dingue et
oui c'est un couple qui qui a contracté
la maladie à la suite de piqû de
moustique tigre pendant des vacances aux
Antilles ils sont soignés ils vont bien
mais par principe de précaution et pour
éviter une chaîne de contamination une
opération de démoustification débutera
ce vendredi soir à 23h l'objectif
éradiquer les moustiques tigres dans le
quartier du ripau à veignier où réside
le couple les détails de l'opération
avec Aurélie Renaud il est noir et blanc
et mesure entre 5 et 7 mm le moustique
tigre il transmet des maladies
tropicales comme la dingue dans le
quartier du ripau un couple de retour
des Antilles a contracté la maladie
l'Agence Régionale de Santé a ordonné un
traitement ciblé contre le moustique
tigre dans cette zone qui compte une
vingtaine de maisons il y a la police
qui a fait qui est allé voir sur chaque
maison et bien euh pour donner un un
flyer qui donne les explications il y a
l'accueil de laamériie qui est l'
téléphone de l'Amérique qui a répondu
aux différents appels des des gens qui
étaient interrogatifs inquiet ouou qui
avaient besoin d'un peu plus de
renseignement que ce qu'il y avait sur
le flyer à partir de 23h ce vendredi une
société spécialisée pulvérisera un
insecticide dans toute la zone
pavillonnaire le produit est projeté par
des engins portatifs d'une portée de 15
m les habitants du quartier comme
beréranger installés depuis 6 mois
devront rester chez eux a demandé de bah
moi d'ouvrir le portillon pour qu'ils a
accès au jardin et puis de fermer les
volets les fenêtres vider tout ce qui
est écuel des animaux et cetera pour pas
évidemment les empoisonner je trouve ça
étonnant choquant mais faut faire ce qui
est demandé dans tous les cas il y a pas
le choix c'est la première fois en
indrloir qu'un tel traitement de
démoustication est effectué l'ARS
indique que les produits utilisés ont
les mêmes matières actives que les
antimoustiques disponibles en pharmacie
mais plus puissants on cherche à tuer
les moustiqueques du quartier parce que
ces moustiques ont pu piquer la personne
ou les personnes malades qui ont
fréquenté ce quartier et vont pouvoir
contaminer d'autres personnes du
voisinage on cherche à couper la la
chaîne de transmission de la maladie
après la pulvérisation les riverins
devront laver leur mobilier de jardin
attendre 3 jours avant de consommer les
légumes du potager et privilégier les
activités d'intérieur pour les enfants
pendant 24
heur